Let's analyze this algorithm.
What we want to know is how much work is it going to take for us to complete this algorithm,
how many operations are we going to do, and how many steps is that going to take?
So the analysis is straightforward.
For either flavor, inclusive or exclusive, for each of the n iterations of the loop,
we take 1 step and we do 1 operation.
Thus we require n operations to complete the algorithm, and we also require n steps.
But the parallelization of this algorithm is more complex than with reduce.
With reduce it was really clear that the different pieces of the computation tree
could be computed in parallel. With scan this is much less clear.
So the questions you should be asking yourself now are
a) how do we compute scan and parallel at all,
and b) how can we reduce the work and step complexity
of a parallel implementation as much as possible?
But even before we get to those 2 questions, let's answer a larger question.
Why do I care about the parallelization of scan in the 1st place?
So here's a high level, intuitive explanation.
Many computations have the following form.
We want to process a list of inputs, which I'm showing here with blue circles,
and create a list of outputs, which I'm showing here with red circles.
And we begin by computing this 1st output from this 1st input.
Then we use that 1st output and the 2nd input to compute the 2nd output,
use that 2nd output and the 3rd input to create the 3rd output, and so on.
For instance, in our checkbook example we used the previous balance
and the next check amount to compute the current balance.
This creates a dependency structure that looks like what I've drawn in green.
When we structure our computation like this, we see that it has no apparent concurrency.
We're only doing 1 operation at a time.
First we compute the 1st output, and then we use the 1st output as an input to get the 2nd output,
we use this output to get the 3rd output, and so on.
Now, this is a very serial structure, and if we implement it in this way
it would be a poor fit for a GPU indeed.
Computations like this can often be expressed as a scan.
And if we can characterize our computation in terms of scan, that's great,
because--let me tell you a little secret--we can parallelize scan
and make it run fast on a parallel processor like a GPU.
Now, not all computations with this sort of dependency structure
will fit into the scan model, but many will.
And for those computations, leveraging an efficient parallel scan implementation
turns the problem from something that would be a poor fit for a GPU
into something that is now a much better fit.
So how do we parallelize a scan computation?